fast sieben monate krieg in der ukraine
und wir wollen anfangen mit bilder aus
der stadt kobe eine großstadt im zentrum
der ukraine und wir sehen dort wurde ein
damm zerstört und zwar einen damit über
dem fluss in hulett wir sehen hier
dieser staudamm der nach dem angriff
gestern morgen völlig kaputt ist wir
sehen hier verschiedene soldaten die
gerade versucht ihnen zu reparieren und
dieser damm hatte ganz verschiedene
bedeutungen für die ukraine nämlich zum
einen hat er die 650.000 menschen in
calgary mit strom versorgt zum anderen
war aber auch wichtig für die
wasserversorgung weil auch trinkwasser
gewonnen wurde aber es gibt noch eine
weitere bedeutung dieses damit wie sich
irgendwie während wir hier sehen wie die
überschwemmungen eine ganze brücke hier
mit sich mitreißt und diese weitere
funktion des dammes war eine die
russland am wichtigsten sein dürfte denn
wir sehen hier am ende der
der damm hat den fluss in hude letzten
nämlich sozusagen gestoppt und hat ihnen
hat ihn festgehalten und dieser fluss in
letzte der es extrem wichtig für die
ukrainische armee denn wir sehen hier
diesen fluss weiter im süden wir zeigen
das recht auf der karte und wir sehen
wir einen schützenpanzer darüber fährt
und dieser fluss ist derzeit extrem
flach das heißt der pekings extrem
niedrig weshalb die ukraine darüber
kommt und russland scheint diesen pegel
steigern zu wollen also nach oben
verändern zu wollen so dass die ukrainer
nicht mehr über diesen fluss kommen wir
sehen uns das ganze mal auf der karte an
des südens bei der ukraine hier oben die
stadt coari da gab es den angriff auf
diesen dampf und der in roulette der
ebenda gestaut wird der geht hier lang
und geht hier dann in den apple sein und
die ukrainische angriff richtung seit
mehreren wochen ist eben genau hier über
den damm prima man versucht also hier
ein russisches gebiet vorzudringen hier
hat man es auch bereits geschafft einen
brückenkopf zu schlagen auf der anderen
seite des inhalts und die russen
versuchen seit wochen immer wieder diese
puncto brücke die die ukraine errichtet
haben dort zu zerstören aber wir haben
hier ganz aktuelle aufnahmen von dieser
ponton brücke und man sieht einfach mal
die liegt mittlerweile auf dem grund des
flusses dh die ukrainer wir sind jetzt
hier einen rechts einen ukrainischen
schützenpanzer die brauchen gar keine
ponton brücke mehr sondern die haben
eine echte brücke wenn man so möchte und
warum ist das so weil der fluss so flach
ist
großen schein mit dem angriff auf den
damm diesen flusspegel hier steigern zu
wollen so dass die ukraine eben nicht
mehr über diesen dann kommen dass also
neben dem ganzen terror gegen die
zivilbevölkerung die haben keinen strom
mehr die haben kein wasser mehr die
haben große überschwemmungen eben auch
offenbar ein militärischer ja ein
militärischer verzweiflungstat der
russen die hier sagen okay wenn wir
diesen fluss nun mal nicht flacher
machen könnte diese brücke nicht
zerstören können dann müssen wir den
damen zerstören damit der fluss wieder
höher wird wir wollen es auch fotos und
videos aus dem osten des landes
einziehen dort haben wir in der region
aktiv die große gegenoffensive der
ukraine gehabt und wir haben bis zu 300
russische panzer und schützenpanzer die
dort zurückgelassen wurden von den
russen und die im teilweise zerstört
sind aber zu großen teilen auch
weiterhin funktionieren und wir haben
dieses bild was wir aus dem anfang des
jahres kennen nämlich ukrainische bauern
die hier einen russischen t 72 hop
kampfpanzer einfach mal mit sich
mitnehmen abschleppen die ukrainische
armee hat kann ich die kapazitäten diese
ganzen zurückgelassenen waffen
mitzunehmen deshalb werden wieder bauern
geholt die mit ihren traktoren kommen
und die schleppenden die panzer dahin ab
wo sie ihn repariert werden sollen um
danach eben für die ukraine russische
einheiten zu bekämpfen zu guter letzt
wollen wir uns noch ein video ansehen
was wenn man so möchte gelegt wurde ein
kleines geheim video aus deutschland
nämlich das zeigt die panzerhaubitze
2000 zuerst sagte man das wäre ein video
aus der ukraine
aber das scheint ein video zu sein
während der übungen während des
trainings hier im april und mai was die
ukrainer selbst aufgenommen haben und
das ist eben ein übungs video ist sieht
man an diesen granaten das sind mich
blaue granaten übungsgranate die ganz
offensichtlich nicht in russland
eingesetzt werden hat gegen russland
eingesetzt werden sondern anfang des
jahres eben mit der panzerhaubitze 2000
eingesetzt wurden das scheint also ein
erinnerungs video zu sein wenn man so
will ukrainischer soldaten aus
deutschland mit der panzerhaubitze 2000
die übung und das wurde jetzt
veröffentlicht man sieht also die
ukraine haben offenbar ja während ihrer
sechswöchigen ausbildung hier auch spaß
gehabt und auch videos gemacht zur
erinnerung an deutschland und zur
erinnerung an diese deutsche
unterstützung die sie bekommen haben im
kampf gegen russland
[Musik]